something I was like I wonder if Joe
knows this totally random but just look
how cool is freaking signs it's pretty
cool they measure like the stress levels
of whales and they can use the stress of
whales to determine if like the Soviets
are or Russians are testing bombs under
under the ocean floor like what the hell
I heard this talk recently this woman
studying whale ear wax so whales don't
have ears like ours that stick out and
they not be good for like swimming
around right there's a lot of friction
but they have like these vestigial
things cuz they like evolve from wolves
I always thought like stuff came out of
the water and that whales evolved into
wolves no no they think that wolves
turned into whales really yes wolves yes
I don't know this Jamie H cuz I am a
total ignoramus but this is a going
theory that whales evolved from wolves
so like most mammals they have ears
those ears have been covered over and
what happens to a whale is that it
retains ear wax and the ear there's ear
wax in the whale the whale doesn't hear
with its ears it hears through its
Jawbone
uh and that reverberates and that's how
it sens it sound but it still has
vestigial ear wax they sample the ear
wax of dead whales and they can measure
how much cortisol the stress hormone is
in the whale and they know the migratory
patterns of the whale science and they
do some of this research in Antartica so
anyway that's really fascinating I want
to understand how you can look at all of
the variables that are possible in terms
of the composition of planets in terms
of temperature in in terms of also
different kinds of environments for life
that we haven't encountered yet but
could be real different kinds of life
things that are very very alien to what
we perceive of as carbon-based life
forms I just don't understand how you're
looking at one planet that has a very
different environment than Earth even
though Earth has life and it doesn't and
using that one example to sort of
dismiss the possibility that in the
insanely vast universe that there
couldn't be something that's very
similar to the conditions of Earth yeah
100% right you're 100% right and I'm not
saying that I'm not saying there's
there's I'm ruling it out I'm saying
there's what's called evidence prior
information right and you should be able
to say that How likely it is like you
should be able to run a simulation say
for every time there's a planet that's
rotten with life like the Earth there's
some odds in the overlapping communal
history of those two planets in a binary
Planet system that they should share
life and you'll get a number I'm not
saying I know that number but you should
be using that as information
to sort of say how how what is theity
How likely is it for life to get started
and once it starts going I believe
Evolution can take over but you just
keep you know kind kept this notion that
because the universe is so vast but I
the reason I brought up Antarctica I've
been there twice okay there's four
different animals that I've seen in an
arch okay and there are these giant
seagulls called skas that will freaking
rip your face off if you leave it out
you know they're just nasty Birds okay
there's Penguins on the continent itself
and uh there's seals and then there's
people okay so this is 17th of the
continents of Earth there's almost no
other life on Earth but imagine you
could make the same argument the Earth
is so big then like wherever there's a
continent there should be life you don't
see cities in Antarctica you don't see
other uh not even like other people you
don't see like well there's still
neanderthals down there there were
dinosaurs there at one point but I'm
saying right now so just by saying that
there's the large number hypothesis
is that there's so much possibility that
that leads to probability that's a
logical fallacy just because there's a
large number there's a there's AAL if
Earth didn't exist but Earth does exist
and humans do exist and and Earth is
Rich with life forms we know that it's
possible that's true and we know that
it's possible given the parameters that
Earth enjoys that's that's what I say if
and we know that there's an insane
amount of planets out there that could
replicate this environment right so
wouldn't you then say again if you knew
knew that life is is so incredible
there's these extremophiles live in
volcanic vents 3,000 M under the ocean
um so again you have to say like what
are the odds that we would not see Life
on Mars or on incel and I'm not saying
again I'm not saying there's it's just
Mars it's one example and it could be
that life requires a very narrow window
that we enjoy sure that may be but but
look at all the other factors that go
into life existence on Earth and we
talked about Jupiter before there are
are scientists that believe that without
Jupiter we wouldn't be here cuz Jupiter
is like a big vacuum cleaner there are
scientists that believe that if the moon
wasn't as close as it is you know that
the Moon is exactly the same angular
diameter as the sun from the earth do
you know what that implies for you and
and next April 8th when I come and visit
you again there's a total eclipse of the
sun oh wow so I'm going to take you if
you're willing I'm going to take you
show you the that sounds like a lot of
fun uh it'll change where we go uh we're
going to go up to San Antonio oh nice
we're going to drive it's easy or we'll
fly we'll get this only a 90 it's not
even 90 minutes right have you ever
experienced a total solar eclipse um I I
didn't experience it cuz I I I remember
was it Donald Trump that was staring at
the sun wasn't it it was him yeah it was
it was him and I was like I'm not going
to be that guy I think I did try to look
at it yeah now that I remember but it
didn't come through here so anyway no it
was in California if you were to see it
you would the the experience that you
had on Mona will seem like you know like
you're just going down to the to the bar
or something really this has changed
your life okay I'm in this will change
your life damn it we told everybody
we're going to San Antonio on April 8th
it's gonna be a real problem well we'll
find a secret place freaks yeah exactly
going to show up